[Applaudissements]
des applaudissements
ils ont été très nombreux lors de la
marche blanche organisée mardi soir en
l'honneur de samuel pâtit ce professeur
d'histoire géographie assassiné par un
terroriste car il enseignait la liberté
d'expression à ses élèves
des milliers de personnes ont participé
à cet hommage locale la marche blanche
est partie du collège le bois dole où il
travaillait pour rejoindre la place de
la liberté
un symbole fort voulue par la
municipalité entre tristesse colère et
vocalement cette marche blanche n'est
pas neutre la liberté d'expression ce
n'est pas qu'un mot c'est la liberté de
lire c'est résister penser c'est la
liberté d'écrire faire la liberté de se
syndiquer fait la liberté de s'associer
fait la liberté de revendiquer fait la
liberté de voter et ça on ne me
l'enlèvera pas beaucoup de sentiments en
fait
de la tristesse parce que ça ça reste un
acte terrible confluence est passé de la
ville inconnue à une ville qui fait la
une des journaux et pas forcément pour
les bonnes raisons
et puis certaines elle c'était
nécessaire parce que je pense que tout
le monde était très touché moi ma mère
est enseignante
donc je comprends totalement
l'aberration qu'on a tous face à face à
cet événement
samuel patier désormais un symbole celui
du garant des valeurs de la république
grâce à son enseignement la liberté
d'expression mais aussi la fraternité et
l'égalité continueront à être transmise
comme l'attestent en de ses anciens
élèves devenus professeurs ça me touche
vraiment ça touche aussi mes élèves
il ya deux jours enfin dimanche soir
j'ai reçu un mail d'une ancienne élève
et elle m'a dit qu'elle était touchée
que que dans mes cours
on donnait beaucoup d'importance aux
débats et du coup bas à travers monsieur
pâtisser leur rappeler les cours qu'elle
avait avec moi et ça m'a vraiment
interpellé parce que moi je lui même
s'est bâtie il m'a transmis quelque
chose et peut-être qu'à mon tour j'ai
transmis quelque chose aux générations
suivantes
samuel pâtit recevra la légion d'honneur
à titre posthume
ce soir un dernier hommage national
cette fois ci lui est rendu à la
sorbonne à paris